our subject for this evening jewish
christians and christian jews what did i
say
jewish christians and christian jews
a certain man had two sons
and the younger of them said to his
father
give me the portion of goods that
falleth to me
and he divided unto them his living
and not many days after the youngest son
gathered all together
and took his journey into a far country
and there wasted his substance with
righteous living
and when he had spent all there arose a
mighty famine in that land and he began
to be in want
and he went and joined himself to a
citizen of that country
and he sent him into his fields to feed
swine
then he would feign her fill his belly
with the husks that the swine did eat
and no man gave unto him
and when he came to himself he said
how many hired servants of my fathers
have bred enough and to spare
and i
perish with hunger
i will arise and go to my father and
will say unto him father
i have sinned against heaven and before
thee
and i'm no more worthy to be called thy
son
meet me as one of thy hired servants
and he arose
and came to his father
but when he was yet a great way off
his father saw him
and had compassion
and ran and fell on his neck and kissed
him
and the son said unto him
father
i have sinned
against heaven and in thy sight
and i am no more worthy to be called thy
son
but the father said to the servants
bring forth the best robe and put it on
him
and put a ring on his hand and shoes on
his feet
and bring him to the fatted calf and
kill it and let us eat and be merry for
this
my son
was dead
and is alive again
he was lost
and is fine
and they began
to be merry
now his eldest son was in the field
and as he came and drew an eye to the
house he heard music and dancing
and he called one of the servants and
asked what these things meant
and he said unto him
thy brother is come
and thy father have killed the fatted
calf because he hath received him safe
and soul
and he was angry
and would not go in
therefore came his father out and
entreated him
and he answering said to his father
lord these many years do i serve thee
neither transgress i at any time thy
commandment and yet thou never gave us
me a kid
that i might make merry with my friends
but as soon as this thy son was come
which hath devoured thy living with
harlots
thou was kill for him the fatted calf
and he said unto him
son
thou are ever with me
and all that i have
is thine
it was meat that we should make mary and
be glad for this
thy brother
was dead
and is alive again
and was lost
and is found
god is good
and all the time
i like the words the father said to the
son
thou are ever with me and all that i
have
is that i told a few nights ago
god wants to give us
everything in jesus
what the father said is true all that i
have
is thine
all the resources of the universe
are under the control of christ for the
benefit of the church
and i've put all things under his faith
and gave him to be the head over all
things to the church
ephesians 1 the last two verses
all things are under christ's feet
for the benefit
of the church
what a remarkable thought all the
resources and riches of the universe
christ will draw from that
as we have need
good evening everyone
you look nice you always do thank you
for that
it's always nice to talk to a nice
looking congregation you look like
children of god we thank god for his
undying love did you have a good day
so did
i can't complain at all i thank god
for putting me in a perfectly
comfortable place not far close to
everything so i thank him for that
and when i stay in the room wherever i
stay i develop an attachment to the room
because that's where i pray and meditate
and read the bible and elon wife and
pray and meditate and wonder lord how do
i deliver this message and so whether
it's in the basement or in the roof it
is my upper room are you following me
so that is my i was in england a few
years ago to speak
maybe i should not name the country but
anyway i already have
and i was put in a little place called
the hotel
when i stretch my hair my hands hit both
sides of the room so you understand
where i was the closet could not close
because my suits were
protruding out so the door couldn't
close
there was a community bathroom other
people in this really was a house using
the bathroom and there was a little sink
in my room
and i all night all i heard was sirens
going up and down police sirens
ambulances
and after two days the pastor came by he
didn't know where he was
he came he said is this where they put
you i said yes he said come let me take
you to a real hotel i said no no no
i've already established a spiritual
connection with this room
and i can't leave to go somewhere else
this is now my upper room my holy place
and so i wherever i go if i stay it
becomes my holy place my upper room
where i pray and wrestle with god and
ask him what he would have me to say and
so i thank him for i am at red
roof is there anyone with us tonight you
are not assembly advertised you are here
for the first time raise your hand
first time
ah what's your name
nice to see you
thank you thank you very much for coming
may the lord bless you and every member
of your family say amen from the
government all right anybody else
you're here ah what's your name
mark
mark oh mark you've been here before
good to see you by the mark saw your
last night i believe it was god bless
you mother mark you told me you would
come back and you kept your word
god is a god who keeps his word mark is
a man who keeps his amen from mark
save with more energy
thank you very much all right everybody
else
oh
where is this elizabeth
oh hello elizabeth how are you
that's a good bible name like there's a
little one between gilman and
elizabeth my song
what's his name
jordan
joey doctor joey all right nice to see
lil joby elizabeth and gilman god bless
you all and i mean that very sincerely i
told you whenever i say god bless you
i'm saying a prayer with my eyes open
three words in the prayer god bless you
and so that's my prayer for you for
those of you online wherever you are may
the lord bless you as well the fact that
you're online does not change the power
of god god can bless you via youtube
facebook zoom you name it and so may the
lord bless all our online guests and
visitors and members our subject for
this evening jewish christians and
christian jews what did i say
jewish christians and christian jews
before i get into that remember preserve
reference in god's house if you don't
need this as a bible please make sure it
does not ring in the presence of god
let me check mine
i thought mine was off and it wasn't
now it's off
all right
number two why i'm speaking pray for me
and say lord put your words in that
man's mouth jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9
then the lord put forth his hand and
touched my mouth
and the lord said unto me behold i have
put my words in thy mouth and i want to
speak god's words so that you might be
blessed and favor number three think as
you listen
isaiah 1 18 come now let us reason
together said the lord let's borrow
heads and pray
our fault in heaven
your word tells us in isaiah 42 8
i am the lord
that is my name
my glory will i not give to another
father in heaven i have come not to seek
your glory
not to seek my glory i shall say but to
bring glory to your name by presenting
thus saith the lord
i ask you to cleanse me from all that is
unlike your father
remove from me any
sit vessel in your powerful hands
i ask you to bless those who are
listening open their minds that they may
receive the word and respond to the word
this is your will for them
bless those in the building those are
lying
father bless the visitors i pray in a
very special way touch their lives their
god let them know remind them father
there is a god of the universe who loves
them personally
bless our online guests and friends and
members bless every country where this
program is now being viewed bless the
leaders guide their minds that all the
decisions may allow the gospel to go
forward
and if there's anyone listening father
who has covered 19
or any of his variants
in the name of jesus christ for whom
nothing is impossible
heal the night prayed a god for your
glory in their lives now father speak
through me i pray
in jesus name let god's people say amen
and amen what's our subject
jewish christians and
christian jews john chapter one let's
read from verse one
john one
reading from verse one
and i read from the king james version
of the bible
are you with john 1
reading from verse 1 we read 1 2 3 then
we go to 10 and 11.
the bible says in the beginning was the
word and the word was with god and the
word was god
the same was in the beginning with god
all things were made by him and without
him was not anything made that was made
let's read verse 14.
and the word was made flesh and dwelt
among and so who is the word in verse 1
jesus christ he was the one who was made
flesh that's how one verse helps to
explain another now let's go to verse
10. like there yes he was in the world
and the world was made by him
and the world knew him not
i wonder what that meant how that made
christ feel he was the creator of the
world he came to the world in our form
and the world did not recognize it verse
11 is even worse he came unto his own
and his own received him and so in
person we have the entire world but in
verse 11 we have the jewish nation
he came
to his own people
and they received them not
they rejected him
let us go to john
john 19.
history from verse 5 our subject
jewish christians
and christian jews
john 19 from verse 5 then came jesus
forth wearing the crown of thorns and
the purple robe and pilate saith unto
them what behold the man when the chief
priest therefore and officers saw him
they cried out saying what
crucify him crucify him by saying unto
them take ye hope taking him and crucify
him for i find no fault in him the jews
answered him in verse 7 what did they
say tell me
we have
a law
and by our law come on he ought to die
why
because he made himself
the son of god by saying he was the son
of god he was saying he was equal with
god i want you to observe two things
when the chief priest therefore an
officer saw him they cried out saying
crucify him crucify him
bible said unto them he him and crucify
him
the jews told pilate in verse 7 we have
a law
and by our law
he ought to die
they were using the law
to get rid of
come on
christ the creator christ
let's go to verse 15
of john 19.
but they cry what are they saying
away with him away with him keep reading
crucify him paul says unto them what
shall i crucify your king the chief
priest said what
we have no king but caesar
get rid of him
when pilate brought baramus and brought
jesus whom do you want whom do they
choose barabbas get rid of jesus why we
have a law
the jews back then
they were using the law
to get rid of jesus
if that's clear
say amen
now let's go to colossians chapter 2.
we read from verse 14
it's very popular with people who do not
like to obey god's law
colossians 2 reading from verse 14 our
subject jewish christians and christian
jews is 20 minutes after 7 i'll release
you before or by 8 o'clock
blowing up the handwriting of ordinances
that was against us which was contrary
us to us he took it out of the way
nailing it to the cross and having
spoiled principalities and powers he
made a show of them openly trying thing
over them in it let no man therefore
judge you in one
in need
or in drape on respect of a holy day or
the new moon or of the sabbath days wish
are a shadow of things to come but the
body is of christ now people who don't
like god's law they use verse 14 to 16
all the time to try to prove what
the lord
yes but how was the law done away with
according to their reckoning based on
verse 14.
look at 14 and blowing out the
handwriting of ordinances that was
against us that was which was contrary
to us he took it out of the way finish
the verse
nailing it to the cross
now modern christians
they use christ to get rid of what
the law
are you with me
the ancient jews they use the law come
on talk to me
to get rid of christ
we have a law
and by our law you have to die someone's
they have been sending me texts on
twitter i haven't responded
this is a new covenant
so consequently the law no longer
applies
we live by faith not by the law we are
using christ now to get rid of the law
we have jewish christians
and in these modern times we have
christian jews because either way
getting rid of the law is getting rid of
christ getting rid of christ is getting
rid of the law
because the law is a transparent come on
of the character of jesus and of the
father
we have jewish christians
and we have christian jews
back then
kill christ
use the law to do it
today
kill the law use christ to do it let's
take a look
at the law
before i get into that let me pray again
father
the subject of the law is absolutely
essential
because if the law had been obeyed there
would have been no need for calvary
give me the right words i pray and let
those listening allow the words to
convict them in jesus name amen
go with me to
romans chapter 3
romans 3.
you read 19 and 20.
you have romans 3 19 and 20
for we know
that what things so ever the lord saith
is said to them who are under the law
finish with me now that every mouth may
be stopped and all the world may become
guilty before god every person born of
adam since he sinned has come to this
world needing a savior
first 20 what does that say
therefore by the deeds of the law there
shall no one
be justified in his sight for by the law
is the knowledge of sin
the purpose of the law is to reveal to
us
sin
the devil has gotten into preachers
to say
there is
no law
if there is no law read my mind what am
i about to say
there's no sin
so do as you please
remember the law was satan's original
target
why do i say that
satan wanted worship
the backboard of worship the spinal cord
of worship is obedience that's why
samuel told saul have the law as great
delight in burnt offerings and
sacrifices as in obeying the voice of
the lord they hold to obey is better
than sacrifice
and the harder than the fat of wrath let
me pause on that then we'll get back to
romans 3 19 and 20.
the holy spirit told samuel to tell saul
to obey is better than sacrifice
to obey one
the law of god
is better
than sacrifice
because if lucifer had obeyed god's law
even not a father
but more particularly if adam had obeyed
god
we would not be in this position now
there would have been no need for the
cross of calvary there would be no need
for christ to come in human form if
that's clearly a man though the bible
says to obey is better than sacrifice
what sacrifice
christ
on the cross
had there been no sin
there would have been no need
for a savior
or to obey is better than sacrifice
and so when lucifer wanted the angels to
worship him he had to attack the law
because there's only one way to
demonstrate love for god and that is by
obeying god and jesus christ who created
the angels who commanded the angels and
whom the angels worshiped he told us
when he came to this world if you love
me come on finish it
that's the only way to worship god or to
show love obey him in order for satan to
take the love of the angels from god to
himself he had to undermine the law of
god
he hasn't changed
and so he gets into preachers we're back
to romans 3 20 now
and men stand in pulpits
and preach there's no law
because the carnal mind
is enmity against god
for it is not
subject to the law of god
let me make that clear and even more
embarrassing
every person born since adam fell
is born or has been born with an
inability to obey god it is a natural
genetic inability to obey god every
person born from king to whomever who
was just born five seconds ago in the
hospital is born with a genetic
inability to obey god's law
because the law is litter and spirit
you've got to obey both levels
the law is a reflection of the character
of god how can a fallen person
express the character of god let me say
it again the carnal mind the way we're
born is enmity against god there's a
natural hatred in every person born a
natural hatred for thou shalt not thou
shalt not and thou shalt not
even if you leave aside thou shalt not
we don't like people to tell us what to
do
someone asked you to do something the
person better use a nice voice
and make it sound like a favor because
it sounds like an order your response
would be who do you think you're talking
to
that's the way we don't tell me what to
do
we're born that way
we hear god's law
that's why jesus said he must be born
again you've got to come back a new
birth it is real it is spiritual but it
is as real as the physical birth there
is a change
you come with a heart
that is willing to obey god
and so the bible says
therefore by the deeds of the law they
shall no flesh be justified in his sight
for by the law is the knowledge of sin
the law tells us this is wrong this is
right
let's look at the law again as we
continue christian jew jewish christians
and christian jews the next chapter
romans 4 let's read verse 15
because the law worketh
wrath keep reading
the way there is no law there is no
transgression where no law is there is
no what do you mean by the law working
wrath
what's the wages of sin
the condemnation of the law is all a
sinner can expect because the sinner is
naturally unable to keep the law
until christ comes
and by conversion christ comes in
the person takes on the spiritual nature
of christ and that nature says i delight
to do thy will oh my god yeah thy law
come on is within my heart that's the
converted person
and so the law work is wrath for the law
breaker
i'm always driving around my town
wherever i go i see policemen i just
drive by
i walk somewhere i see a policeman i
just keep walking but if i'm a criminal
when i see a policeman i start to get
nervous why because i'm a law breaker i
am under the condemnation of the law of
the city or the state or the county
[Music]
let's go to romans five
theory 12 and 13 our subject jewish
christians and christian
jews romans 5 reading from verse 12
read with me
wherefore us by one man sin entered into
the world and death by sin and so death
passed upon all men for all have sinned
for until the what law
sin was in the word in our words long
before god gave the long sinai to moses
sin was in the world
from adam keep reading but sin is not
imputed come on with there is no law now
paul says before the law was given to
moses until the law when christ came
down on sinai
the same was
sin is not imputed come on but there is
no law
so from adam the law has been affected
before adam the law has been affected
what satan sinned
the angels are followed him sinned
the lord's meanings in existence
because sin can only exist
where there is tell me allah
7 30
lucifer
sinned
by breaking
god's law he said i will be like the
most high i will be my own god what does
the bible say about the first
commandment thou shalt have no other
boss before me
he was thrown out
the angels who listened to him second
peter chapter 2 verse 4 for if god
sprayed not the angels that sinned
revelation 12 9 and the great dragon was
cast out daryl's sermon called the devil
and satan he was cast out into the earth
and his angels were cast out within the
bible says they sinned they violated
god's law because lucifer became their
god
sin
when adam sinned he broke the law
what are genesis 3 2 sorry genesis 2
adam broke the law
look at verse 16.
well by the way before we read that and
there's someone listening to me right
now
a precious precious family that i love
i won't name the country but
they kept telling me please greet the
church for us
and i kept forgetting
i want to know while near the country
there's a lovely family in kenya that
sends regards to you shall i send your
regards to them
all right so i and now i'm clear i don't
have to go to the guillotine i have done
my duty and i've given you the greeting
from that beautiful family
in nairobi kenny i know sometimes what
are watching right now so i am in
declare i have saved my life all right
we're in genesis chapter 2 read verse 16
now you read 16 and the law of god
command stop
what did the lord do come
here 3
let's read from verse 9
are you there
and the lord lord called unto adam and
said unto him where are thou
and he said i heard thy voice of the
garden and i was afraid because i was
naked and i hid myself verse 11 and he
said who told me that thou was naked has
now eaten of the tree whereof i
commanded him
to command twice
let's go to verse 17
and unto adam he said because thou hast
talked unto the voice of thy wife and
has eaten of the tree you read it
of which i commanded this
how many times do we see command
what did adam violate
the command of god
the only way to sin is by violating the
command of god the law of god
adam
broke the law let the bible give us a
definition of sin first john chapter
three let's go there quickly towards the
back of the bible find revelation jude
third john second john first john
chapter three we read four and five
read microscopically
and you should be telling me slow down
preaching
but you know
oh thank you
god bless that lovely sister god bless
her oh okay
our first job
okay yeah that's good
way down all right oh yeah first john
three
we're there
let me pray again fathers i continue to
speak thank you let the spirit really
slow me down i pray in jesus name amen
verse 4 of first john 3
whosoever what committed sin stop
whosoever
what's
is the world the only place where
intelligent beings live
what is who's yes
any intelligent being
anywhere
who sins
has broken the law
whosoever
committed sin
transgressive also the law
are you following me whosoever covers
the universe
not just chester tower or michigan
now
read verse 5 carefully
before you read verse 5 there are two
things we have in verse 4 neighbor for
me
no two things
law
and sin are you with me do you see them
you're looking at me but do you see them
first john chapter three verse four
there are two things in that verse i
want you to identify
law
and sin
do you see them
who has not seen them
all right now keep those two words in
mind read verse five
and you know
that he was manifested
and in him
what were the two things we saw in verse
four
come on say again
[Music]
which one appears in verse five
which one does not obtain verse five
what happens to sin in verse 5
what happens if you read the verse what
happens to satan in verse 5.
it's taken away
but we have two things one of the two
come on come on
what are the two things in verse four
sin come on
and law is that clear
which one is taken away which one is
left
could jesus have taken away the law no
no
it's his character
[Music]
that'll be suicidal
he takes away
sin
and leaves
oh god
amen ah thank you
that's a vegetarian amen
okay i'm speaking by faith
amen he takes to his sin and he leads
now
while the law cannot save you
let's see what the law does
go to romans 7.
what's your
subject
jewish christians
what did the jews back then try to do
destroy christ using what the law would
modern jews try to do christians
destroy the law using christ
all right romans 7 let's read verse 10.
and the commandment come on
which was ordained
to life
i found to be unto death
pause
you don't need the university degree to
understand the bible
just read carefully
the commandment means the law which was
ordained
to life
while the law does not
give you life it
preserves that life
why did death enter
what is sin
transgression
[Music]
then
it brought death
then how do we receive life
yes
obedience
is life
disobedience that is there
the commandment which was
ordained to life now we see that all the
way back in the garden of eden let's go
back to chapter 2 of genesis our subject
jewish christians and christian jews and
we're saying back then 2000 years ago
the so-called people they used the law
to kill christ today christians use
christ to kill the law
of course they'll never succeed either
way
they did kill christ back then when he
actually gave up his life
genesis chapter 2 let's read verse 16
and verse 17.
are you there
the lord god commanded the man saying
of every tree of the garden thou missed
freely eat paul's
you know god gives us freedom
he gives people the devil is so clever
he's gotten us to believe coming to
christ is bondage
what did
let me leave uh
genesis 2 16 for a minute
let's go to exodus don't go just stay
where you are
what did god tell moses to go and tell
pharaoh
let my people go what is that
freedom
what were they in
now why did moses say
give me a name because i have to tell
them who sent me
they're forgotten who god wants them
in egypt could they do whatever they
wanted
what were they
slaves
god had to use force to get them out of
the pharaoh's hand
he delivered them and he said to them
come on free
then in chapter 20 he tells them keep my
commandments
i have set you free
in order that you may be able to come on
my command
because obedience means freedom
i have set you free
to obey me
[Music]
so i'm 105.
let's read 44
and 45.
this is a historical psalm it gives a
record of god's deal with the israelites
from abraham all the way down to our
entering at the canaan land verse 44
read that for me
he gave them the lands of the heathen
and they inherited the labor of the
people now why
finish that chapter
that they might
observe his statues come on and keep his
laws
they could not do that where in egypt he
had to set them free in order they might
be able to obey him
obedience my listening friend wherever
you are is freedom
but the devil has twisted the minds of
many christians they regard obedience as
bondage and so christ has set me free to
disobey
now let's go back to genesis 2. it's a
16 minutes to our 8.
verse 16
of genesis 2
our subject
jewish christians and christian jews
read with me and the lord lord commanded
the man saying of every tree of the
garden thou may freely eat but of the
tree of the knowledge of good and evil
thou shalt not eat of it and pause now
before we finish it pause
for in the day thou
[Music]
and so god says
in the day thou eatest in the day that
you disobey me finish 17
you will die
disobedience leads to
will turn that point around if adam had
obeyed what would be preserved
listen to me
obedience
is life amen
the bible says
if you break one
you break on
so for those who are breaking the
seventh-day sabbath commandment
in the eyes of god you were breaking
talk to me
how many crimes you have to commit to be
a criminal
one
how many people do you have to shoot to
be a murderer
if you shoot my little toe have i been
shot yes or no yes
obey god
please
christ died because somebody disobeyed
and the devil has gotten into christian
preachers to preach there is no law
can you think of a greater insult to god
by saying there is no law you're saying
there is no righteousness the bible says
that the righteousness of the law might
be fulfilled in us when only the days of
christ throughout the history of
salvation the righteousness of the law
has to be fulfilled in us
you dig into the law what righteousness
will be fulfilled in us there is no
righteousness to be fulfilled if you
remove the law because the holy spirit
tell paul to say the righteousness of
the law has to be fulfilled in us and
god has only one kind of righteousness
that is very life
let me recap briefly
two thousand years ago
i called them jewish christians
they used the law
to kill jesus
today
modern christians are using jesus
to get rid of the law
the crime of the jews
was rejecting christ the crime of
christians is rejecting the law
and both are guilty of rejecting christ
i want you tonight
to say lord
even though every other person on earth
rejects your law
by your grace
i want to live in obedience to your law
can i see your right hand
you will you say that genuinely
stand up with me
and i'm talking to those of you online
do we not understand when christ comes
back he's only destroying those who have
broken the law
the very revelation has seven blessings
here's the last blessing and for those
modern day christians who said christ
got rid of the law 60 years later here's
what the holy spirit of christ told john
to write
blessed are they that do his
commandments
that they may have right to what tree of
life what is do his commandments give me
one word
it gives you a right to what
tree of life we have obedience and life
let's pray
father in heaven your word is so simple
if it's read honestly
dear god
implant within us
a love for your law
a love amen
obedience
helps their god to see obedience not as
an isolated thing we do but as a life we
live
because obedience is righteousness and
action
obedience is the life of christ in
action because christ said himself i
have kept my father's commandments
thank god
two thousand years ago
the jews that we call them on the basis
of tonight's
title the jewish christians
use the law
to get rid of christ
today
the christian jews as i call them are
trying to use christ to get rid of the
law
but father let us stand between these
two groups as a small gathering of
people who will say
though he slay me yet will i trust him
and the only way to trust you is to obey
you
we're not paid to be saved we're obeying
because you have changed us and given us
our obedient nature
we thank you for the lord that god it's
the law of life it's the law of
righteousness it describes us holy just
a good why would you get rid of
something that god that is holy just
good righteous and perfect
change the hearts of those who are so
hardened against your law suffer them to
the point that the spirit of god may
write this law of life on their hearts
please hear us pray god please
save us when you come
in jesus namely god's people say amen
and amen
[Music]
so
you